du côté du concours lépine la matière
grise est toujours au rendez vous cette
année
la pince à rouler pour retourner les
merguez du barbecue a enfin été inventé
elle est en compétition sévère avec le
prêt stubb à dentifrice la fin
prévisible de bien des disputes matinale
petit résiste en latex
vous pensez à quoi eh bien non
j'espère gagner avec ça at il ajouté
voici la solution offerte aux joueurs de
pétanque
cet objet rend service à ces sportifs
qui ont besoin de ramasser les boules et
parfois aussi de se désaltérer
si on vous après avoir lieu car à cannes
est contré par terre que les chromes ils
viennent de gens où qu'ils soient
mélangés avec les gens de l'inde était
dans le compartiment où le procès par
terre et vous savez que c'est la vôtre
vous prenez votre ticket reçu que vous
placez sur les lanières vous permet vous
ouvre de l'autre côté le ticket ringer
et par le cas vous avez indiqué que
c'est un peu plus grand vous mettez tout
simplement concentré porte-cartes vous
fermez votre côté le ticket ranger si
vous avez un examen à notre compte
vous le mettez au milieu on l'oublié
et voilà c'est génial et le tricot fera
cap toujours à portée des mines pourquoi
pas un cendrier électronique ayant
vraiment la forme de soucoupe volante
j'ai eu un flash le plh est sur la table
c'est ce cendrier là je peux le tester
j'ai une sensation bien génial